[Music]
[Applause]
uh joe torre the hall of famer uh mlb
special assistant to the commissioner
and uh won four world series titles was
the yankees with the yankees and he was
there
that night and joe joins us now joe
thanks for joining us what do you think
about when you think about that night
uh
just horrible i mean i got numb
uh uh and
you know it's still when i when i think
back and you and you're never gonna
forget you never wanna forget
but uh
you know you're real yeah you know there
are a couple of different emotions i
mean you were scared you were mad
uh
and
[Music]
just uh 9 11 was
such a tough day i i didn't even have
the tv on because i was scheduled to do
a uh charity luncheon
that day and i was just getting myself
ready uh in my bedroom and a
car service called me and said well i
guess it's canceled they said what are
you talking about and
turned on the tv and uh
saw
what was happening like everybody else
and uh
you know really baseball went on the
back burner for me to be honest with you
dan because
what was what was happening right then
was just
something that
never thought you'd ever see
and then when baseball came back
what were your emotions
well you know you had some time to think
about it
i'll tell you what really
moved me off the fact that you know all
we do is play a game
was on the saturday after uh
9 11
we were we were in new york we hadn't
started baseball yet as far as games
and we was decided that we're going to
start get it cranked up again on monday
so we were going to be on the road so
saturday i had a workout for whoever was
left in new york because a lot of my
players
got in the car and drove home i know
pettit and uh
and clemens drove back to texas together
and uh
you know so we were we were going to
have a workout at yankee stadium on that
saturday
and then afterwards
you know we had a good number of players
and some coaches
we've gotten bands and and went to
ground zero
we started out actually at the javits
center
where
it was a staging area where all those uh
first responders and
firefighters uh from all over the
country
were you know basically living uh you
know they were
sleeping there and eating there and uh
just taking their turns going back to uh
to the towers to see if they could
rescue and then you realize
over time it was just going to be a
recovery and um
and and then we went from
from the
javits center
we went to saint francis hospital
with hopes of you know that we could
visit some victims but there were no
victims there the only ones that were
there were
again firefighters who had smoke
inhalations issues
uh and from saint francis we went to the
armory now
i i was a little hesitant or a little
sensitive about
uh going in the armory because this is
where the family members were waiting to
hear
uh get dna results from uh
you know from their their loved ones and
um
and
so we we finally realized that we should
go in we did go in
uh those people were separated that the
floor of the of the um
of the armory was
was completely
filled
and it had like low partitions
separating the families
and groups of people
uh counselors and clergymen
were there and
and this one family we were walking
around
the perimeter
and this one family sort of signaled us
to come on over
and we walked over toward this uh this
family and and bernie williams
uh
said to this woman he says i don't know
what to say to you he says but you look
like you need a hug
and with that he grabbed her and hugged
her and
it sort of loosened up everybody else
they started coming toward us
and bringing pictures this is what was
so powerful to me dan was they were
bringing pictures of their
of their loved ones
wearing yankee
you know jerseys and caps and jackets
and
saying what a big fan
he was or she was and
and it was at that point that i realized
that
you know even though
all we did was play a game it was a game
that that people really uh
needed to have at that point in time as
to sort of get in the way of the horror
they've been going through
and at the time i don't know if you feel
like you're helping but you're also
intruding
at the same time
dan there was no question that was the
hesitancy i had
that we were intruding on their private
you know serious time
uh and sad time
and and really that's when
you know someone had gone in
uh
randy levine who was our president ran
in and he waved us in about five minutes
later and and they wanted us in there uh
because we i i can't tell you how long
we spent there but we spent a good deal
of time
and people
were
we're looking for
and distraction i don't think a strong
enough word but they wanted somebody to
get in the way of what they were dealing
with
what was that moment like when uh
president bush went out there and threw
the first pitch
well you know we had just lost the first
two games in arizona uh to the
diamondbacks so this is our first game
at home
and
you know it's interesting you always
have a meeting
um
because they were there there was
a curiosity whether he was going to be
there or not they never definitively
said he was coming but which you can
understand
but
both managers and general managers
always win the umpires room about an
hour or so before the game
to have a meeting with you know with the
umpires just to go over
the local ground rules and and stuff now
we had had this meeting in arizona but
this is the first game in new york
and you go around and you know you shake
everybody's hand you shake all the
umpires hands and all of a sudden there
was an umpire you didn't recognize
and you realized it was a secret service
man
uh
in an umpire's uniform in an umpire's
uniform and when when president bush
threw the first pitch he was standing
around home plate with all the other
umpires
and um
but when when president bush came
through the runway
you know into the dugout i i met him at
the mouth of the the runway
and he said to me he says you're going
to kick their butts i said we're going
to try
and with that he just uh
you know crisply went up the steps and
and out to the mound
waved to the fans
and had a very determined look
of going right to the top of the mound
which you come to find out later on that
derek jeter sort of dared him because he
was telling them all the bad things that
new york fans will do to you if you
don't get on top of that
so uh
and and and by the way president bush
you better not bounce it so um
all that and i and you know i was at an
event with the with the former president
uh a couple of years ago
and he was telling that story
to uh
to the people he was uh he was speaking
to was really funny that derek basically
threatened them you know but he went out
there and and i'll be darned if he
doesn't throw a just throw a strike
right there
and and you know here's jeter adding
levity to
a serious moment because you know i was
told that the president may have had you
know a vest on a bulletproof vest on is
that right
he did have that and and derek warmed up
with him in the batting cage underneath
the stands
and you know because he that's the one
thing he didn't want to do is bounce it
he wanted to show strength he felt that
was a part of it and of course derek you
know he's got that that sort of dry
sense of humor because of uh you know
everybody should be as comfortable in
their skin as derek jeter and uh
and and he
and
and as i say the president uh you know
obviously took it the way derek meant it
and uh
you know he he was pumped i mean he
he felt again that he needed to show
strength and he went out there and
certainly
answered the belt
coming up tomorrow it will be at city
field where bobby valentine will throw
out the uh ceremonial first pitch with
you
are you going to the top of the mound
though joe
no well uh
i hope not and if bobby valentine is
going to the top of the mound you could
that that may be the first fight we have
uh
tomorrow night because um
i'm
you know
my heart would be in the right place but
i'm not sure the ball would be in the
right place so we're we're probably
going to cut it in half did you ever
yell at jeter
that i i i did yell at cheater but uh
for what
well there there was a play that
about spring training
actually his first spring
um
you know where he didn't cover second
base
he likes to tell the story
uh where you know he didn't cover
second base on a on a play it was it
would have been the third out of an
inning and he assumed they were going to
throw it to first and
he didn't cover second
and
you know he come in and got on deck and
and stuff and
i just told him to
get his head out of you know what and
you know get with it and
i i even forgot that whole thing he had
to remind me
but there was a time also in chicago
where he tried to steal third base with
cecil fielder hitting and and we were
one run behind and two out in the eighth
inning and
uh i threw some stuff in the dugout
which thank goodness nobody videoed but
uh
and when he came in i said i remember
saying to don zimmer i said i won't
won't talk to him because this was his
rookie year i said i'm not going to talk
to him until tomorrow i just don't want
to distract him we're trying to win a
game
and with that after the half inning was
over he came into the dugout and he
wedged himself right between zimmer and
myself he just come over to take his
lumps you know that was it so i hit him
in the back of the head i said get out
of here because that told me he knew
that he screwed up but
he
he was a gamer he came to work every day
and he knew that uh he was just one of
the guys and
really earned earned
uh earned a lot of respect from the
veterans that first year uh which is
very surprising for a young player how's
the arm i mean you played third base and
you were a catcher you you how's the
hose can you can you still get it there
well i had all rotator cuffs into
surgery since then which should make it
better but uh i may be able to throw it
damn but i'm not sure exactly what
direction
didn't you once what was the batting
average 363
363 yes
and you and you weren't exactly
you know fast
like no i i i didn't get many of those
hits right
it was it was a magical year don't ask
me but it was
it was a special time and
[Music]
363 though i mean yeah i had 230 hits it
was crazy it was crazy
i also have you for 23 stolen bases in
18 seasons
not bad
uh you know i tried to i tried to steal
once in every part of the country this
way it would be a shock
to i remember tom seaver tom seaver was
on the mound one night and and i'm gonna
you know and the only time i would try
to steal was like if it was two strikes
on the hitter you know and stuff like
that where he'd get a free count next
inning
and tom sieber would always come to a
you know a set position and look over to
first base and then with pitch
so
he did that and he looked over to first
base and when he went back to
you know looked toward home i took off
and then he looked back over there and
he still threw home figuring i'm not
going to make it anyway
yeah but that yeah i uh 23 stolen bases
that may have been inflated but see what
happens uh thanks again for reminiscing
and uh have fun with bobby valentine
tomorrow and this weekend joe it's
always great to talk to you
thanks dan same here that's joe torre
hall of famer and uh major league
baseball special assistant to the
commissioner it'll be the yankees and
mets at citi field tomorrow night bobby
valentine who was the mets manager back
uh
you know following 911 and uh joe torre
the ceremonial first pitches